britain is the hardest hit country in
europe with more than 52 thousand
coronavirus fatalities the british
government is trying to stop the spread
of infections
with a citywide testing program in
liverpool that city alone had more than
1300 new cases last week operation
moonshot they're calling it uses
technology from a california company
along with help from the military
charlie dagetta is in liverpool for us
where he took part in the experiment
charlie good morning
good morning to you tony you know in
china they managed to test
nine million people over the course of
five days here in liverpool it's more of
a
voluntary measure but already about a
quarter of the population
has taken part they answered a call to
arms
soldiers and civilians alike like
teaching assistant jackie vaughn
we just don't want to be walking around
being non-symptomatic
and spreading anything at all liverpool
already had one of the highest infection
rates in the nation
when the entire country plunged into a
second lockdown
mayor joe anderson said the virus was
out of control
whilst we've got no vaccine being
distributed
circulated yet it's a tool it's a tool
in the armory and it means that we can
break the chain of infection
about 2 000 members of the military have
been deployed to test centers including
liverpool's famed anfield soccer stadium
the first part of the test is familiar
that rather unpleasant swab test
down the throat and up the nose the
difference is these results aren't sent
off to a lab
they're processed on the spot the
majority of samples undergo
lateral flow testing to detect covid19
antigens in the swab
in just 20 minutes mine came back
negative
the government now plans to roll out
this pilot program to 67 more areas
nationwide before
christmas missing this year will be the
mayor's older brother
you know when you look at my brother's
death certificate and it says covert 19
on it that's the reality this virus
exists
it's there it takes no prisoners it's
got no heart
um and it will come for you
if you deny it it will come for you
the liverpool city council said nearly 2
000
people have tested positives since the
program began
a lot of those people had no idea they
were carrying kovid they are now
self-isolating for the next couple of
weeks anthony
farley dagetta in liverpool as he said
if you deny it it will come for you
thanks charlie